20:18 for me has been all self-work now
I'm normally pretty passionate about
personal development but this year has
been crazy I've treated my bros like my
motherfucking job if self-help will
crack I have been smoking crack this
entire time and lot of it and one thing
that occurred to me is that I should ask
all the people who are closest to me
what they think my biggest flaw is
because they know me best and because I
have no objectivity when it comes to
myself and you might be wondering you
know why what why would you do that
do you like pain do you want to cry that
sounds like a terrible idea
oh but no it's not it is in fact
fascinating to hear the people you love
the most tell you what your biggest
freakin problem is and I will admit okay
I went into this naively thinking like
in the back of my mind I mean I've been
in therapy for so long you know and you
know so helps kind of make things so
maybe when I ask them they're just like
I can't really think of anything are you
perfect and I'm a silly little fool yeah
pretty silly little fucking fool now a
word of caution do not ask people this
if you're not fully ready to hear the
answer I was an M really down for
criticism of myself as a human being
because I want to be better I am just
naturally curious about what people
think of me and I have the time to like
mentally prepare to hear their opinions
without any defensive nough so though I
encourage you to also seek out your
flaws don't do it if you ain't ready so
here's what they said and the most
interesting thing I want to point it out
now is that every person I asked preface
their flaw with almost this exact
sentence well it's a little strange but
fascinating and I'll come back to that
later but now friend one said well it's
also a strength but I would say your
need to control is probably your biggest
flaw I mean it's good because it allows
you to like run a set and like be a boss
but whenever you feel out of control you
just
spiral that would be surprising because
I kind of know I'm a control freak but I
didn't realize everyone else also knew
how much of a control freak I was friend
to said well it's like also in your
strengths but I feel like you kind of
have a chip on your shoulder and so you
feel like you have to work so much
harder than everybody else like prove
that you belong there I don't know if
it's consider you're like a woman or
like a woman of color but it's always
like you're working three times harder
to prove that you had just as good as
the guys that won really threw me I
didn't see that coming at all but once I
thought about it I was like okay I can
totally see that I see how that's the
thing huh and finally a friend three
said well it's hard because I think it's
a strength but sometimes you get really
obsessed and this can be good cuz like
if you get obsessed with like an idea or
project the next time I see you it's
like done but then I've seen you get
obsessed with the person and that seems
really emotionally exhausting for you
and it definitely is for me oh I know
I'm well aware of that one and I am
working on it but what I loved about
this exercise was that it made me
realize all of our flaws are probably
our strikes just the flipside of them
because when I think about some of my
friends and their flaws I think the
exact same thing like one of my friends
can be super judgmental and callous and
not very compassionate but it also makes
her incredibly observational accurate
about people's characters and witty as
hell
another friend can be kind of
thoughtless and insensitive about your
feelings but this exact quality also
makes him impervious to other people's
opinions of him and allows him to create
art with a really unique voice without
ever feeling discouraged or influenced
by whatever's popular my last friend is
super self-defeating and can be afraid
to even try but this makes her cautious
calculated really good at evaluating
risk and whenever she does decide to do
something she does it 210 percent
so all of the things that are wrong with
us can be right with us if we know how
to manage them and use the aspects of
these qualities that serve us so what
are your flaws or I guess I should say
are you brave enough to
I'm Anna Akana and I'm a I'm an
obsessive control freak with the chip on
her shoulder but you know awareness step
one
hey thank you to Squarespace for
sponsoring today's video Squarespace has
beautiful award-winning templates and an
all-in-one platform so you never have to
install patches or upgrades ever they
offer a unique and simple setup
experience if you need a domain and
24-hour customer service with
Squarespace you can build any kind of
website whether you're a flawed human
being or a completely perfect one go to
squarespace.com slash ana to start your
free trial today and use the offer code
and app for 10% off at checkout